what's the status of the Zika outbreak
in Brazil right now how quickly is its
phrenic hi mark wearing high alert with
Zika here right now the Health Ministry
is investigating 4,000 babies with
symptoms of microcephaly a malformation
related to Zika to the pregnant mothers
being contaminated with the virus the
first cases were identified just a few
months ago so you have an idea of the of
the quickness with which the virus is
spreading right now fabiola is the
brazilian government making any progress
right now in efforts to contain the
virus mark it's a tough fight because
we've got to fight the mosquito spread
but yesterday the defense minister came
out to say 200,000 soldiers will be on
the streets fighting the virus sorry the
mosquitos ads Egypt e which is the one
that spread not only Zika but also dengi
and the chikungunya fever the way to do
it is to prevent them of breeding so
they have to eliminate all spots of to
water you can have an idea of how hard
it is to do in Brazil because here we
have a lot of plans it's a tropical
country and the mosquito is really
everywhere we've already been following
a big spread of dengue in the last years
now Zika fabiola we have about 30
seconds in addition to the human impact
how's the spread of the Zika virus
impacting Commerce how are companies
dealing with this well right now we
already felt some impact on tourism so
the airlines are offering cancellations
or changes of tickets for pregnant
clients that don't want to go to the
areas affected and also you know it's
it's a terrifying story I myself have a
couple of pregnant friends where you
know by mosquito net
and you know all sorts of insect
repellents it's we're really you know we
have to take care of ourselves because
the virus is really spreading quickly